[Music]
from strange-looking et finger toys to
dolls that send chills down our spine
our childhoods were filled with some of
the most messed up toys ever stick
around to see one of the creepiest dolls
we have ever seen hey guys check out our
new member of the family toy hub toy hub
is the ultimate place for kids to get
their daily dose of crunchy slime
squishy slimes sticky slime play-doh
color learning and so much more we have
lots of fun with the most awesome toys
and amazing stories for kids make sure
to show it to all the kids in your
family and while you're there make sure
to subscribe and hit that like button at
toy hub it's playtime don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to our
Channel now get ready because we're
about to check out 10 most messed up
toys for kids the jolly chimp toy
monkeys are usually soft fluffy and very
cuddly but this is not one of them
there's a good chance you've seen this
kids toy and several messed up movie
scenes because this toy is kind of
messed up we have no idea why this
exists but a part of us is secretly
laughing at it of course were also a
little bit creeped out
it's the symbol monkey also known as the
jolly chimp or Charlie Chip we're not
sure what's up with the face and it
definitely doesn't look like a toy that
kids would play with the truth is the
jolly chip is actually a vintage toy
that's been around since the 19th
century when it was used by street
musicians the symbols keep going and
going until you make them stop by
turning off the battery unfortunately
the monkeys odd face never seems to
change those facial expressions actually
come from the original Japanese version
from the 1950s and believe it or not
it's eyeballs would pop out even more
and the monkey would even screech this
musical monkey went through several
different changes and even got
discontinued at some point the current
version of Charlie chimp has been around
since 2004 and it's still one of the
most recognizable toys out there however
we're pretty sure that it's also the toy
that appeared in most horror scenes 8
these finger-like even Ellen DeGeneres
was horrified when she stumbled upon
this very interestingly shaped et finger
light toy you've heard of 18 right it's
a story about an alien who gets stranded
on earth and becomes best friends with a
boy called Elliot et has a glowing
finger which he can use to heal injuries
at a large distance sounds pretty cool
right well this toy was supposed to
represent ETS finger according to the
box it also glows as you press the
button
according to eBay this is a vintage
collector's item as it's so old its
batteries are no longer working but
that's not the reason why we're putting
it on our messed up toys list it's on
here because it looks like an
inappropriate toy the design is supposed
to represent et's alien finger but most
people will see a completely different
thing we can't imagine how the
manufacturers managed to get away with
this design because this shirt doesn't
look like a toy a child would you it
wouldn't be the first time we came
across a toy that's definitely not meant
to be child friendly but the et finger
light is our own personal winner in this
category et phone home and tell them
that this is definitely not what your
finger looks like at least we hope it
doesn't see monkeys yes we also added
the ever-so-popular sea monkeys to our
list we bet you owned at least one of
these sets during your childhood the
concept of the toy is pretty
entertaining put the powder in saltwater
and you end up with cute sea monkey
looking like creatures the popularity of
the sea monkeys started off in 1957 when
the owner harold von braun hood became
fascinated with the species called brine
shrimp after studying them he realized
the animals could stay alive even
without water using their protective
casing this inspired him to take a
package of powder put it in water and
then see it come to life strange to
think that animals we call sea monkeys
are actually powdered shrimp right with
that being said they were initially
called the inst
life but the shrimp's tales inspired the
name behind the toy monkeys you know
today see how different it sounds
knowing you're getting see monkeys
rather than instant life shrimp
here's another thing that's quite
unusual about this toy the packaging
doesn't even make sense as the creatures
look absolutely nothing like they do in
the picture
the popularity of the toy also required
the owner to crossbreed shrimps as their
real life expectancy is just too short
seems a bit messed up that we're
purchasing animals that don't look like
they should even be used as toys in the
first place right this unfortunate seems
now this one is just really disturbing
and we can't imagine why any child would
want a toy like this these are called
roadkill toys and what you see here is a
pretty grotesque scene of a crocodile
eating a baby while this particular toy
is not for sale we did manage to find
several similar plush toys that are just
so bizarre we really can't wrap our
heads around why the fact someone would
want to buy these for their child a UK
website that sells unusual gifts listed
these toys as not the most tasteful
things ever but there are perfect choice
for people with a sense of humor
according to them the collection
includes different characters that have
met their destiny while crossing a
highway we're sure there's only a
handful of children out there who would
cuddle up with a toy like this and we
can't blame them having stuffed toys in
your life is actually beneficial for
children from a very young age babies
use them to become familiar with
different surfaces toddlers make them
excellent companions and preschoolers
involve them in all sorts of imaginative
play while this channel definitely loves
talking about some of the weirdest
things we can find on the Internet a
roadkill toy for children is just not
one of them Batman
water gun sometimes toy makers don't
really think things through and this
Batman water gun toy is definitely one
of those cases it's not the first time
we've witnessed an inappropriate toy and
it's definitely not the last this Batman
water gun is definitely one of those
boys that got one of the most
unfortunate designs ever we're not
particularly worried about the way this
Batman stands we're just more grossed
out to see where the water gun trigger
is whether this was an intentional or
unintentional
Nuendo it's safe to say it's one of the
most messed up toys we've ever seen this
Japanese made toy existed back in the
1960s and it's sold as a vintage
collectible and it's not just the front
trigger that's disturbing wait until you
see the part where you're supposed to
put water in Japan is known for unusual
out-of-this-world toys but this seems
like a pretty bold move for the 1960s
doesn't it and yes Batman
actually existed way before the 1960s
the first version of the superhero
appeared in 1939 but we can imagine that
people back then never thought someone
would design a Batman water gun that
looked like this what do you think is
this an acceptable toy or is it best to
stay away from it and leave it out of
children's reach the breastfeeding doll
if you watch our videos you've seen us
mentioning weird toy concepts like
baby's first baby that actually turned
out to be a statement project
well the breastfeeding doll is not a
statement project it's an actual toy
available for purchase and we're really
not sure how we feel about this it's
called the bag glutton which translates
into gluttonous baby and it was created
by a Spanish company back in 2009 the
toys mission is to educate children on
breastfeeding and while that's
understandable by some parents others
were completely grossed out and argue
that children are far too young to
understand the concept of breastfeeding
this doll also comes with a
breastfeeding bra which allows girls
aged as young as eight to pretend to
breastfeed their young babies the bra
even makes a suckling sound just like an
actual baby does when breastfeeding
we've definitely seen some educational
toys with some of these bizarre concepts
but we're not really sure how we feel
about the breastfeeding doll nowadays
many high schoolers also have classes
where they have to take care of a robot
baby to prepare them for Parenthood
these babies have to be burped their
diapers have to be changed and they need
to be fed otherwise they get cranky just
like a real baby and while that's
completely normal we're not sure how we
feel about babies breastfeeding babies
and unicorn meat this might not look
like a toy but we promise it actually is
it'll question everything you've ever
known about mythical creatures and
resurface the Google debate on whether
or not unicorns exists it's a box of
candy unicorn meat but what's even more
disturbing is the fact that you get a
slice of unicorn toy on the inside we
have to admit that this is actually
pretty clever but since unicorn dark
hits favorite we can imagine some might
be pretty upset by this toy the
description of this toy jokes about the
fact that the so called meat tastes like
rotisserie chicken with a hint of
marshmallow sweetness
it also features crunchy unicorn bits
that provide an excellent source of
calcium of course this is all just a
joke because the product you receive
isn't actually edible we can't decide
what's more messed up while we think the
concept of candy unicorn beat is
actually pretty clever
Dinah's sliced up unicorn toy might
really traumatize kids if you believe in
unicorns in any shape or form it's
definitely recommended to stay away from
this kids toys on the other hand go and
how to read at the description of this
toy as it's absolutely hilarious
would you ever eat candy unicorn meat if
you actually could let us know in the
comments Breaking Bad dolls
our channel featured several bizarre
dolls we managed to find online but this
one is one of the most controversial
ones we could find if you're a Breaking
Bad fan this might make you just a
little bit angry while Breaking Bad is
indeed a popular show and there are
several people out there who would
collect these dolls are still a
children's toy and many just don't see
why kids should be subject to Breaking
Bad storyline these awesome-looking
Breaking Bad dolls were distributed by
Toys R Us in 2014 and pulled from the
shelves after a mom from Florida
launched an online petition to
discontinue the dolls which are
promoting illegal substances and include
some questionable
objects as props Breaking Bad storyline
is definitely not meant for children and
although many adults enjoy The
Adventures of Walter White it is
inappropriate to promote his life
choices to children of course the fans
of the show started their own petition
to keep the dolls and many sick if they
love a 3d representation of their
favorite characters and it's unfair to
discontinue the toys many argue that
there are far many other questionable
toys out there that are
way more aggressive than the Walter
White doll what do you think about this
doll that features a bag of narcotics
money and Walter White holding a gun rad
repeat in Tarzan you might have seen
this toy on Ellen DeGeneres because she
was just as surprised by its movement as
we are Tarzan is definitely a beloved
Disney character he's strong and he has
an unusual story that captured our
hearts and taught us to be better human
so we're not entirely sure how to feel
about this unfortunate kid's toy that
somehow hit the store show to make
Tarzan move we need to press a button on
his back the hero will then raise his
arm up and down while releasing his
famous battle cry well we have nothing
against his battle cry we definitely do
see an issue with this incredibly
suggestive motion of his arm there's
absolutely no need to ruin your
childhood by giving you this mental
image what do you think is this an
appropriate motion for this Tarzan toy
it's speculated that The Legend of
Tarzan was actually based on a true
story of William Charles Milton who
spent 15 years living in a jungle after
being shipwrecked although we have no
confirmation of this particular fact we
can definitely confirm that this toy is
one of the most messed up toys for kids
we've ever seen we apologize in advance
for ruining your childhood and hope you
can forgive us by checking out the next
messed-up children's toy baby reptile
this is a toy that easily sends chills
down our spine every time we look at
this picture don't stare at it for too
long we're still word but accidentally
make it come to life we have discussed
creepy reptile toys and creepy babies
but we have never come across anything
as disturbing as this toy luckily this
is not available for sale in major toy
stores but it is handmade by a woman
called cat who spends a lot of her time
scoping some of the creepiest toys
you've ever seen doesn't it look like a
baby lizard except it has a lot of baby
hands instead of animal feets this
definitely gives us the creeps and
there's no way we're letting this thing
go anywhere close to children you could
of course argue that these are just a
fantastic DIY way of recycling dolls but
you also have to admit that these are
totally creepy however it is not the
first time we
a creepy baby doll like that well it's
much less disturbing visually this
mechanical baby doll also deserves the
bizarre award we're not sure what the
fascination is with turning baby dolls
into something other than adorable but
it's safe to say that parents will
definitely not let any of these toys
come in contact with children did you
play with anything weird as a kid let us
know in the comments that's it for this
video don't forget to give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one check out 10
strangest reasons kids toys were banned
in schools see you next time
[Music]